now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
try and consolidate some of knowledge
that we've been developing over the last
three or four lessons if you hadn't
worked this out about me already
I love tables because tables help me
organize information especially when
there's lots of confusing stuff a list
is confusing but this actually lays it
in an order that I think is helpful I
hope is helpful okay so what we're going
to think about is the different route is
the first in a second you can see one is
the columns in one of the rows and the
influence they have on the shape of the
curve the geometry of the curve we've
already begun to explore this but I want
to do this in more detail so let's start
over here on the left hand side these
things which I guess they look gray for
you but over here this is which
derivative again this is the first
derivative very good so when you know
that the first derivative is positive
what does that tell you about the graph
about its shape it starts with an i we
use the language right it's increasing
very good so that's right it's
increasing and we know when the
derivative is zero like at the bottom of
that parabola we looked at we call that
stationary fantastic and then just going
all the way down the last one here when
the derivative is negative we call that
decreasing fantastic all right excellent
excellent now we know this is out the
first derivative we've been working with
the first student for a little while but
now I wonder if you can think to the
second derivative this is the most
recent lesson we did it doesn't tell you
about increasing decreasing it tells you
that's something different that starts
with the letter C does anyone remember
what it was John concavity fantastic so
when the second derivative which you can
see up the top there when it's negative
which way is the concavity facing and
the answer is it's facing down negative
means concave down we'll skip all the
way over to the right-hand side the
table for a second we'll come back to
the middle if it's the opposite way if
your second derivative is positive then
it's concave up right now just before we
move to the middle of this section right
we just did this example question which
was x squared right we differentiated
once we got the derivative we
differentiated again we got second
derivative and we noticed I write this
we notice the second review was two it's
always two no matter what value of x so
you can see that means that that
parabola
is always concave up what you already
knew which I thought without the
language of second derivative but this
is how you can tell from the actual
numbers okay now I said I would come
back to the middle if you're not concave
up and you're not concave down
you have no concavity so we'll come to
what that looks like in a second all
right all right now the way we're going
to do this is a very very weed and out
of order so I apologize that from the
outset we'll start from the top here
increasing so we're gonna have a look at
the first row here everything we're
gonna do in the first row is going to be
an increasing function of some kind so
increasing means you start low and you
go high start low go high
so what I'd like you to do with me is
draw a series of dots here let's start
low from the left and then go high to
the right okay all these functions are
going to start at the bottom and then
they're going to end up somewhere higher
than where they begin okay so I'm gonna
go from bottom left to top right okay so
let's think about we'll do the right
hand what I said I was gonna do this
order out of order let's do that concave
up one for a second because you just
drew one of these on your page I've got
an increasing part of the function in
fact I asked you to highlight it and
it's concave up so what does that look
like well it's gonna look something like
the right-hand side of the parabola that
you drew right does that make sense you
can see I'm going up but importantly my
concavity and I'd love you if you've got
another color here to indicate that
concavity is facing upwards okay so this
is the right hand side of the parabola
that I asked you to highlight so that
part's concave up let's come back to the
left hand side now it's still an
increasing function but what does it
look like if it's concave down hmm
now maybe you can do it with your with
your hands right like what was this
gonna look like right I'd love you to
draw something that looks kind of like
our mirror
whoopsie-daisy not a straight line a
mirror image of that right so do you see
this is still an increasing function do
you agree with that it still starts low
ends up high but which way is it sort of
facing it's facing downwards right so
that's concave down now we're talking
about if you like it's like when there's
a concave lenss
these are the two halves of a concave
lenss if you like now if there's no
concavity it's not flexing one way it's
not flexing the other so in fact it's
actually just flat right so we could
draw a straight line here from the
bottom left to the top right that's not
a concave up it's not concave down it
has doesn't have any concavity
whatsoever okay all right now I said I
was going to do this out of order let's
get at the bottom of the table right the
bottom the table the bottom row is about
decreasing functions now maybe you can
start to fill this on already because
they're all decreasing everything on the
bottom row I'm gonna start high and then
I'm gonna drop down I'm gonna end low
okay so again start and start and start
and okay again I'm going to start from
the concave up side because you just
drew one of these on that particular
parabola right what would this concave
up part look like you do it your hand
right or with your pen yeah okay so
you're going to get that that sort of
dropping down but it's still facing
upwards you can see right this is the
left-hand side of the parabola you just
true and at this point I hope you're
starting to sense the patterns you're
like oh okay
I'm gonna take the mirror image of this
now what I go over to this other guy
it's decreasing but it's concave down
like so and again that error is very
helpful to show what it looks like okay
last one what's that middle thing you
look like it's gonna be a straight line
right except of course it's going down
instead of going up hmm all right so
fantastic we've got increasing
decreasing concave up concave down let's
start over here in the middle row on the
left hand side hmm
if you've got a stationary point a
stationary point but it's concave down
hmm
let's draw a point right there in the
middle we know at that point it's a
stationary so it's kind of flat at that
point but if it's going to be concave
down it's gonna have to like bend a
little Bright's got a flex downwards
otherwise if it was just
great we were already established that's
got looking cavity right so therefore
it's gonna have to bend downwards on
either side do you agree with that do
you see how I've now drawn something
concave down so everything in this left
column which we've now completed I hope
you can see and you've drawn it so
they're all concave down okay now we
have a name for this kind of point right
this is not just a stationary point this
is also a kind of it's a particular kind
of turning point namely a maximum right
so I would label this as something I
already know this is a maximum turning
point okay we'll go right over to the
opposite side again I'm thinking that
station of course oh yes sorry
you're talking about right there in the
middle yes okay so right the stationary
point and it's kind of hard to say right
because it's only a single moment in
time because as soon as you move off it
you're facing up you're facing down so
it's only right at that point okay so
yes it is a point that's why you can
actually see my dots are on the ends
here but they're right in the middle for
that one good question all right let's
go over to the right hand side maybe
you're already starting to enter today
what's gonna be over there it's another
kind of stationary point so I'm gonna
draw one in the middle
but it's concave up okay good so you've
got this kind of like ball looking thing
like that
I'm your arrow as everything else in
this right-hand column is it's facing
upwards because concave up and what kind
of a point is this it's a minimum
turning point fantastic okay let's see
how well you can go with pattern
recognition now everything in this
middle column everything the middle
column is a straight line right so this
is also gonna be a straight line but
what kind of straight line it's going to
be horizontal isn't it because because
it's stationary look it can't go up
can't go down so therefore I'll draw an
endpoint sorry stop pointing the end
point and it just goes horizontally okay